okay okay so first thing before we get
to the question do you want to respond
to what I just said about marijuana well
as we talked about Starbucks we talked
about our great voter rights bill we
talked about our efforts to be climate
change but for you bill I can honestly
say we got the best weed in the United
States
well regulate it is no record that's
right by the way they'll County would
give you a run for your money they are
but but they're putting a little
pressure on us we've heard from the
Attorney General in Seattle actually and
we need to make sure that they back off
and wouldn't it be wonderful if the
first time Donald Trump said something
that was actually true if he said he'd
leave us alone on our marijuana
decriminalization yeah I hope that that
will occur well Jeff Sessions has said
good people don't smoke marijuana yeah
thank you but are not good people here
okay Michael will you ever release the
contents of the warning shot discs of
evidence you tweeted about oh yeah
possibly it depends on how the case
progresses I mean you know we what's on
it well you know we took that picture
and we tweeted it out and it was exactly
that it was a warning shot to Michael
Cohen the president that if they tried
to claim that my client was a liar after
60 minutes there was gonna be
consequences and it worked and it worked
perfectly because we heard nothing from
them so we have the DVD and we're gonna
release it win and if it's necessary and
we're gonna see what happens with the
case but make
but make no mistake about it it's locked
and loaded yes I mean I've been
listening to yeah all of this about
Trump and watching how this
conversations go in the US and I have
one question about it I mean there's all
these people in the US who are on the
conservative side who are aligned with
Trump for all sorts of reasons and
there's all this tension around his
presidency and attempts to pull him out
of his office for various reasons and I
think what what do you think will happen
if that comes to pass what what do you
think will happen to these people that
have identified with Trump and like how
is it that Republic that that Democratic
types for example are holding out their
hand to say to these conservative types
sort of like welcome back into the fold
because it looks to me for a man out for
an outsider's perspective that your
country is polarizing in a way that's
not good and that you know people are
going after Trump and I understand that
it's not like I don't understand that
but there's all these people that
elected him and that are identified with
him and they're they're not taking this
well you know and so well they're not
they're not it's not and you know you
might not think they're very bright and
all of that and and you know they're
backwards and and and all of those
things but but you but you know you need
to have respect for the rest of your
citizens and if you're if your country
isn't gonna pull itself apart and as you
really see this happening from an
outsider's perspective when I come down
here and I lived in the States for a
while it wasn't like this before
if you if he was just a regular
Republican president with Republican
policies I would say you'd have a point
but what what is so alarming is the
assault on democratic norms what we were
talking about here today
things like threatening to put people in
jail threatening to put journalists in
jail
wanting military parades praising
dictators wanting to be a dictator I
mean we are at a moment here this is I
try to impress on this on the people who
are too young to remember a lot of
presidents and a lot of Elections how
incredibly different this is than
anything that ever came before I never
much liked the other Republicans who
were in office but I have a renewed
respect for them George
George Bush and Mitt Romney would not
have tried to pull this [ __ ] they just
wouldn't
what about Nixon Nixon got caught and he
gave himself up basically well although
although this president makes the
Watergate burglars look brilliant we can
we can be as tough as we're being on the
president I think we should for all the
reasons you just said bill without
telling his supporters that they're
stupid without saying that right of
deplorable z' if we want to bring them
around to what I would say is a more
enlightened kind of thinking and if we
want them to see Donald Trump as someone
who's turned the presidency into one
long infomercial for mar-a-lago you know
we can do that without saying to them
you've been due to your chumps you're
dumb you're deplorable and I think we
need to talk to them with more
generosity than we do
[Applause]
thisis that the left is too preoccupied
with being non-confrontational right the
left is 2.0 that's a good question the
idea that that liberals especially
intellectuals are preoccupied with
politically correct speech that they're
I see I see what and yet no they're
preoccupied with with identity politics
by a large margin and they tend to
categorize everyone by their ethnicity
and their sex and their gender and I
think all that does is turn people into
tribal actors and that the end result of
that is ketosis weren't you also saying
though that that the left is too worried
about offending people I think that that
goes along I will yes but then on the
other hand when the left for example
offends people in the political sphere
you're questioning whether that's
somehow bad for society writ large
well I'm concerned about I don't I think
that those two issues are I think that
those two issues are somewhat separate
I'm concerned about the the dialog in
the United States around the presidency
pulling people people farther and
farther apart it has nothing to do with
the behavior of Trump I think this is an
independent issue you can you can say
positive or negative but he's only
there's night boredom you see I know
that's the thing is it's that's the
issue that's the that's the issues they
supportive and without the circus he's
just a lonely clown yeah but he has
these his people in Congress who are
enablers and this base that it is a cult
of personality
not unlike dictatorships we've seen in
the past I mean he said once famously I
could shoot someone on Fifth Avenue and
not lose any fans hmm
yes and he has proved that to be almost
true I mean we cannot imagine what he
would do where they were turning them
because I don't know what that would be
I don't think it's anything because
whatever it was he would just say well
it's fake news but okay so imagine he's
impeached just for the sake of argument
and Peter are convicted okay either of
those but it seems to me that matters
one he has to leave yeah I know it's not
it's not an unimportant detail but it
still seems to me that it leaves you
with the problem of what do you do with
the disaffected 40s that are going to be
very right about this independent of
trumps behavior kind of like the Sunnis
after we kicked over Saddam well that's
that's a hell became Isis site yes right
I worry about just that this is an
argument looking for an argument rather
than a solution we're not waiting for
impeachment we're making sure that
people understand Donald Trump cannot
stop us today Donald Trump could not
stop me from the first Net Neutrality
bill to make sure people have access to
the Internet he could not stop us from
doing that he cannot stop us he cannot
stop us from acting on climate change
with all this bull v18 saying it's just
a hoax he can't stop us from fighting
climate change he can't stop us from
having the best paid family leave on
sick leave policy he can't stop us when
we demonstrate people progress in our
state certainly is stopping us from
protecting the environment he has signed
executive orders right the first thing
he did in office would he has to sign an
order that said hey you want to dump
your coal sludge in the streams go right
ahead
the head of the EPA is Scott Pruett he's
reversed all of although he just changed
it to the environmental pollutant
pollutants I know but let just say he
can't stop change the tax landscape
everywhere absolutely he's appointing
crazy judges left in right so here's a
change
things as we speak when we don't cover
it because of stormy Daniels but all of
this is going on get used to it okay all
right we didn't get to any questions but
it was a wonderful panel thank you
everybody happy